Portia is celebrating the 20th
anniversary of its Boxster series to
mark the occasion it's renamed the
latest generation the 718 Boxster inside
and out Joe's cosmetic changes have been
made only the engine is a real novelty a
newly developed turbocharged
four-cylinder replaces the previous v6
doesn't a handcart esta Klaus needs Fitz
isn't Portugal taking the new Boxster
for a spin he says the sports car was
first launched 20 years ago the latest
model has undergone some minor changes a
redesigned exterior new suspension and
engine some might be disappointed that
the engine has been downgraded from six
cylinders to four but the Boxster S has
350 horsepower and remains an enjoyable
ride box on offense affairs is feel far
spot smokeless despite the cars smaller
engine it produces 35 horsepower and 60
Newton meters more torque than the
previous model the open-top to cedar is
more powerful efficient and lighter than
its predecessor the double clutch
transmission allows it to accelerate
from 0 to 100 km/h and 4.4 seconds the
Boxster has a maximum speed of 285 km/h
Porsche says fuel consumption is just
seven point three liters per 100
kilometers in Germany the Boxster S
model sells for around sixty nine
thousand euros the father says the
Porsche suspension was overhauled and is
now somewhat stiffer which improves the
cars handling more ambitious drivers
cannot proportions pasm suspension it
lowers the Boxster by twenty millimeters
and when you select the sport plus
option the suspension is even stiffer
and a portion really hugs the curves
using this paddle the driver can switch
gears and this new dial on the steering
wheel allows drivers to choose between
different driving modes so that's so
much for the country roads as Klaus so
far the cars been a blast great handling
excellent traction brilliant
acceleration that gift us nice Somali so
one yet no it's time to try out to
Porsche on a test track to test the
car's limits on the slalom course
Porsche instructor Mattias Huff's lemma
demonstrates the effects of the new
steering system which is ten percent
more direct than before
by anon sucker but he has notes that
despite jerky steering movements the car
remains on track what it is even when
pushed to the limit the box to remain so
stable ride
even changing lanes at 110 km/h and
oversteering slightly is no problem for
the Porsche
back under the country road so how does
klaus rate the new Boxster S overall
my clothes thinks Portia has lived up to
its reputation again even though the new
Porsche only has a 4 cylinder engine and
stil a genuine sports car dashboard